now we have to get back into the news
and think about dead elephants just less
pleasant it's not as nice but in any
case President Trump is walking back his
administration's decision to end a
three-year-old
Obama era regulation banning big-game
hunting trophies from Africa after a
bunch of people who don't know anything
about big-game hunting or conservation
complained on Twitter even Republicans
even conservatives are getting in on
this because people don't seem to
understand the rationale behind big-game
hunting and trophies here uncle Jimbo
explains we only kill animals to quote
send out their numbers if we don't hunt
then these animals will grow too big a
number and they won't have enough food
say you see we have to kill animals or
else they'll die there it is it's simple
enough we have to kill the animals or
else they will die that's very very
simple and you know it's it's comedic
right it's so counterintuitive that
hunting the animals will actually
increase their numbers and lead to more
conservation but just because you don't
understand something doesn't mean it
isn't true shallows are clear right and
so the Atlantic summed up stupid
coverage of this this weekend they wrote
quote if you were an elephant you might
be puzzling over human behavior this
week well I'm not an elephant also
elephants don't puzzle you know because
they're animals but but this is how they
think right if if I were the animal if
animals were like people they'd go
further they say if elephants are
recognized as a legal persons a term the
US courts have granted to corporations
well and and New Zealand has given to a
river and it's been extended to yada
yada yada
it would be more difficult to hunt them
at all let alone import their body parts
right so it is true let me try to
explain this to the Atlantic how an
elephant might not be a person but
corporations are people corporations are
are groups of people they're not groups
of animals they're not buildings they're
not newspapers they're groups of people
working in corporation with one another
and you don't surrender your rights your
constitutional rights just because you
work with other people that's why
famously Mitt Romney he was pilloried
for this but it nevertheless is the case
corporations are people what else are
they
they aren't gates they are and
Correns they are in buildings there
people there groups of people working
together now here is a statistic thirty
thousand elephants a year are killed by
poachers when we're talking about
big-game hunting and giving out licenses
we're talking about a handful of these
things per year we're not talking about
the thirty thousand they're killed
because their tusks are so valuable that
starving people in Africa who want to
make a profit decide to kill them and
they sell an ounce of it and they make a
year's salary according to a 2005 paper
in the journal of international wildlife
law legalization of white rhinoceros
hunting in South Africa motivated
private landowners to reintroduce the
species onto their lands so we're not
just talking about in the preserves that
are held by the public or held by the
government or whatever we're talking
about incentives so when this became
legal the landowners realized oh
interesting if we bring some of those
things on here that are worth a ton of
money and we allow people to hunt for
them then we will make money too as a
result there was an increase in white
rhinos from fewer than one hundred
individual rhinos to more than eleven
thousand even while only a limited
number were killed as trophies well how
does this work it's because conservation
is expensive so you remember this a
couple years ago in May 2015 a Texan
legally shot a critically endangered
black rhino in Namibia so there's the
species of black rhino they're
critically endangered this guy goes over
there and shoots one he bought a license
for $350,000 that was money generated
from the hunt was a totally managed hunt
that money was reinvested in
conservation maintaining habitats
maintaining environments keeping people
around to stop the poachers and the key
here isn't even a money per se obviously
in Namibia three hundred fifty thousand
dollars goes a long way goes farther
than it does in Los Angeles or New York
but that isn't it it's about the system
of incentives just like you know
capitalism as as we describe it and I
don't even like to use that term it's a
term that was invented by socialists to
pillory free markets but freedom
economic freedom free markets protected
by the rule of law and people making
sure there's a level
it's not just about all of the wealth of
producers though it does the reason it
produces that wealth is because all of
the incentives are aligned so if we're
just talking about conservation and only
basing it on altruism there's a limit to
human altruism but there isn't a limit
to human humans looking after their own
interests and hopefully producing good
along the way
meaning property meaning prosperity
meaning jobs for people meaning wealth
to invest in the environment we'll talk
about this a little bit more on Thursday
when we get to Thanksgiving but the
pilgrims learn this lesson very hard
after a couple years incentives are
important here so for instance when this
big-game hunting is illegal when
trophies can be taken home then there's
more of an incentive to have wild land
and less farmland so it keeps the wild
wild why is this
well if landowners can make more money
either the government or private
landowners can make more money from
selling licenses and letting people hunt
these beautiful animals than they can
from farming then they're going to do
that right but but if they start farming
then they're gonna cut down all of the
grazing habitats anyway so controlled
legalized hunting has also been
beneficial for Zimbabwe
elephants now that this is the big issue
people love elephants I love elephants
it's the symbol of my dear political
party where elephant designs and things
like that for just that reason
there are those weird videos of
elephants painting that are very
terrifying you know they're clearly they
exhibit some intelligence so they say
well if we allow this these trophies
then you know then the elephants are
going to be endangered and all of their
tusks are going to be taken and sold for
the ivory but trophy hunting has doubled
the area of that country under wildlife
management relative to the 13 percent in
state protected areas why is that
because there's incentive incentive for
wild areas to remain wild as a result
the area of suitable land available to
elephants and other wildlife has
increased and by the way we're not
talking about post hunt sales so we're
not saying well there will be more and
there will be a freer market and trading
in these things so poachers are just
gonna go ahead and get them and sell
them there first of all they're already
doing that
poaching is the problem these big-game
hunters are statistically insignificant
when we're talking about big-game
elephant
rhinoceros is being killed but we're not
even talking about post on sales we're
talking about trophies so you have to
hunt it you have to get it you have to
bring it home you can't buy it from a
poacher it doesn't change that market
whatsoever now talking just about rhinos
two rhinos per day were killed in Africa
in 2012 well over 700 Africa's there is
700 rhinos South Africa alone 461 rhinos
were killed in just the first half of
2013 South Africa is a major area for
this so we know that that's the problem
the problem is an Eric Trump going and
hunting or some dentist from America or
a guy who purchases a very expensive
permit to go to conservation efforts
it's difficult for lefties to consider
these things beyond the the graphic even
some conservatives have fallen into this
I saw a lot of famous right-wing
celebrities I won't name them because
they're allies and they're usually right
but they were wrong about this saying
this is awful Donald Trump you have to
get rid of this is so terrible but you
know shallows are clear folks very often
you know you see the picture you see the
poor little rhinoceros or the animals or
the cheetahs and you say we shouldn't do
that but your gut emotional visceral
reaction is not necessarily the way to
protect these animals it isn't enough to
say not that one oh look we saved
sessile isn't that okay don't worry
everything's fine now sessile isn't the
issue the issue is 30000 - this is being
killed every year the issue is or
poachers because these these trophies
have value to them and the challenge is
to stop being emotional - stop saying
well as long as we don't see anymore
pictures that's all well and good you
have to think beyond the pictures and
think about creating incentives and
systems that will actually protect those
animals so as a result I hope that
President Trump thinks about this
thoughtfully and doesn't simply listen
to all of the people on Twitter because
people on Twitter very often don't know
a thing